Welcome to toxic Google. Uh, so today
we have a, a special guest with us,
Zaria Foreman, um, who, uh,
uh, my wife grew up with her,
so I've known her for a while, but, uh,
I always remember a few years ago, um,
a photo of her in front of working
on one of her large scale drawings.
I showed up on the front page of
Reddit and created quite a buzz,
like a just like,
I think seeing the artist in
front of this giant work of art,
a big iceberg was just really
visually striking and I feel like the,
the momentum from that is still going
and she's on a fresh off the, uh,
another sold out show.
Congratulations. Um, so yeah,
here is Zaria Foreman to talk
about her new work and uh, yeah,
welcome.
Okay.
Thank you for that intro. I
yes, my mic is on. Okay. Um,
I'm really honored and excited to
be here and today. I thank you,
Phil for inviting me. Where are
you? There you are. And Sad. Um,
and thank you all for
coming. This is just, yeah,
I'm really thankful to be here. So, um,
I consider it my life's mission to convey
the urgency of climate change through
my work.
And to that end,
I've traveled to the polar regions to
capture this unfolding story of ice melts
and also to the equator to document the
rising seas that are a result of the ice
melts and my drawings exploring these
moments of transition and turbulence,
but also tranquility in the landscape,
allowing viewers like you to connect
emotionally with places that you might
never have the chance to actually visit.
And I choose to convey the beauty of these
very remote regions as opposed to the
devastation in the hopes that it
will inspire people to want to help,
uh,
help protect and preserve them.
So I'm just to start out,
I want to play you something that I
recorded on the Antarctic peninsula. Um,
it's a sound piece that just premiered
to my solo show in Seattle, Washington.
Um, and I recorded in 2015 the
winter on the Antarctic peninsula.
And so really subtle sounds.
So I invite you to close your eyes
or just relax in whatever way feels
comfortable for you.
So this sound is fondly referred to as
ice is as you might be able to see if he
squinted. Um, I've also heard it
called Burgee Seltzer and ice sizzle,
which I've adopted is my DJ
name. Um, but when it is,
is the sound of ancient
air meeting new air,
it's the sound of glacial ice melting and
these tiny little air bubbles that are
trapped inside of it breaking free.
And also there's a whirring sound, which
you may have heard in the background,
and those are Gentoo penguins.
So each of these tiny bubbles popping
open contains a treasure trove of
information for scientists.
And I recently met with one
of them named John Higgins,
who is a professor of geosciences at
Princeton University and Higgins and his
colleagues can basically obtain the age
of the ice by studying these bubbles.
And what they do is use very careful
chemical measurements to reconstruct both
the local temperature and
the ancient atmosphere.
So basically how much carbon dioxide and
methane were there from the time when
the ice bubbles were locked
inside of the ice sheet.
So the records from these archives show
basically how our climate has changed in
the past and what that might
pretend for our future.
So it's important information that we
need to know and these ice bubbles are
hundreds of thousands of years old.
Then in this picture I'm holding a
piece of ice that's a million years old
actually. And he, he told me
it was a million years old
after he handed it to me.
I was just like, oh, I got,
don't melt my aunts. Um,
but actually the results
from John's latest trip, uh,
suggest that he collected ice. That's
two to two and a half million years olds.
And it's no news to any of us that these
massive ancient cooling systems that we
have at our poles that can
take millions of years to grow,
are rapidly melting and that that could
have devastating consequences and we
know it actually already is
having devastating consequences.
There is all kinds of horrible news
out there about climate change.
There is the fact that the past three
years have been the hottest on record or
that the polar bear population in
the Arctic is in rapid decline. Um,
and now we're faced with
as an administration that
is choosing to ignore these
problems. I mean even just these last
two weeks felt like apocalyptic to me.
I was,
I mean I'm sure you've heard about the
earthquakes and the hurricanes and I was
just in Seattle last week and there
was literally ash falling from the sky,
from the forest fires fires
in Washington. And so, um,
yeah,
bad news.
But I want to switch gears and tell you
about an interview that I read recently
where Al Gore is talking about how we're
doing in this battle against climate
change 10 years after
an inconvenient truth.
His first documentary and what
he said actually surprise me,
which is why I want to talk about it.
He said,
even though we're behind on the scoreboard
when it comes to climate change,
that the momentum has shifted
and that we're starting to win.
And I think he's right.
I think he's onto something because we
do actually have a lot to celebrate.
First,
of course there's the Paris accord,
which even though the
u s has pulled out of,
I actually think that's a good thing
because what it did was galvanized the
whole rest of the world,
including most major US corporations
to reaffirm their commitment to it.
Um,
Obama managed to permanently ban offshore
drilling and most of the Arctic Ocean
and part important parts of the Atlantic,
which is a huge,
when Iceland and Costa Rica are
one on 100% renewable energy,
solar power in Chile is selling
for half the price of coal.
Even just in the beginning
of this year, we, um, uh,
the world economic forum let us know
that solar and wind is either the same
price or even cheaper
than then fossil fuels,
at least 30 countries nationwide.
There's a long backlog.
What are for electric cars,
there are real solutions that
exist and they're already starting.
We're already starting
to see benefits of them.
And I think it's a pretty effective
tactic to emphasize the positive,
right?
Like a bombardment of terrifying news,
which I just threw at you is paralyzing.
But focusing on the positive
I think is empowering.
So that's what I tried to do with my work
to celebrate what is still here and to
give you,
give viewers the sense that it is still
possible to do something to protect this
earth. It sustains us. So
with that mission in mind,
um, my process always begins by traveling
to these places at the forefront of
climate change.
And while I'm on site,
I take thousands of photographs
and then back in the studio,
I work from both my memory of the
experience as well as the photographs to
create very large scale composition,
sometimes 12 feet wide,
like the one in this video.
Um,
occasionally I'll like reinvent the water
or the sky or maybe change the shape
of the ice just a little bit to
create like a balanced composition.
Um,
but I'd say 90% of the time I'm depicting
the exact scene that I witnessed
because I want to stay
true to the landscape that
actually existed at that point
in time.
Um,
which just something to take note of
is often very different by the time I
finished the drawings
several months later. Um,
so I begin with a really simple pencil
sketch just so I have a few major lines
to follow, maybe the outline of the
iceberg and the horizon line. Um,
and then I typically jump in pretty
quickly with the color layering pigments
onto the paper and I smudge
everything with my fingers and palms.
Um,
I tend to break the pastel into these
sharp shards or I work with soft pastel.
I should have told you that. Of course
it's basically like charcoal, but uh,
colors.
So I'll break it into these little sharp
shards that I can use to render the
finer details on top of the base layer
of pigment that I've already put down.
And typical paper used for soft pastel
has a lot of tooth meaning a very like
textured surface so that it's able to
absorb as much pigment as possible.
Um,
I actually prefer to work on
a much smoother paper than
what most pestel artists
would want because it allows me to get
those finer details without the texture
of the paper getting in the way.
Um,
the challenge with this though is that
there isn't a lot of room for error or
reworking since the paper
can't absorb so much pigment.
But I honestly enjoy this challenge
because I think that I get so lost in the
tiny details that I would just
never know when to stop if you know,
if the pigment in the paper didn't
provide those kinds of limitations for me.
Um,
so I am aware that,
you know,
most people can't access many of these
really remote places that I draw.
And so in a lot of ways the environmental
issues there might seem remote and
disconnected from their lives.
So that's one reason why I choose to work
on such a large scale to recreate the
wonder of witnessing an
iceberg or a glacier up close.
And I rely on other specialists like
scientists to make rational data driven
arguments for why we must take
action to protect our ecosystems.
But through my work,
I'm trying to make an appeal
on a more elemental level.
According to behavioral psychologists,
much of our decision making
comes from our emotions.
And I think art has a special
ability to tap into those emotions.
And it's not just something I think
it's scientifically proven that it does.
So when I make these drawings,
I'm trying to create immense images that
are just overflowing with detail that
draw you in and transport you.
Um, and an author named Elaine scarry,
she's a Harvard English professor,
wrote a book called on
beauty and being just,
and in it she talks about how,
um,
she suggested I should say that when we
witnessed something really beautiful,
be it a wave or a face
or a poem or a glacier,
that it causes an s what she
calls a radical decentering.
And she says, quote, when
we see a beautiful thing,
our own importance is diminished.
It is not that we ceased to stand
at the center of the world for,
we never stood there.
It is that we ceased to stand even
at the center of our own world.
We willingly cede the ground to
the thing that stands before us.
That is the exact experience that
I hope to evoke through my work.
So this past last school year,
I gave a series of lectures at Harvard
University and in my preparation for my
talks,
I was scrolling through
their environmental center's
website and looking at
their, um, climate week from 2015
there were a bunch of videos from,
from it and there was one that
was particularly compelling
to me that featured a
father and son duo,
Bob Cohain on the right,
who's the professor of
international affairs at
Princeton University and his son
not on the left who works at,
um,
on climate issues that the
environmental defense fund.
And one thing that stood out to me that
they both emphasized was this notion of
momentum, the same momentum that
I think Al Gore was talking about,
that for there to be
effective climate policies,
we need people and parties from different
arenas to work together in an ongoing
way.
So that's how I see my work
fitting into the bigger picture.
I just want to be part
of that conversation,
helping to generate momentum and
unity of purpose across boundaries of
discipline and geography
and political affiliation.
So I guess by sharing
these moments of stillness,
paradoxically I'm hoping
to help generate momentum
in their talk.
I also found it really touching to see
how one Cohain had passed the torch onto
the other because I think it taps into
something essential about climate change
work,
which is its purview is intergenerational.
The work is about passing the torch
and thinking ahead several generations.
And I think perhaps I might
be particularly attuned
to that dynamic because of
the debt that I owe to my
mother. Rena baths, foreman.
She was a fine art landscape photographer
and in the last 10 years her of her
life, um, her work focused on the Arctic
and she passed that torch onto me.
My mother's love of photography just
propelled her to the most remote,
far flung places on the planet
that she could possibly find.
And my family and I were fortunate to
join and support her on those adventures
from riding camels through northern
Africa to mushing near the North Pole.
She always said that she was
a polar bear and a past life.
And I never doubted that to be true.
She could just stay out for hours on end
with like frozen eyelashes and a giant
smile on her face. And the rest of my
family was like, I'm hungry and cold. Um,
but she just loved it.
So in August of 2010 and 11,
she and I were planning an Arctic
expedition together to Greenland called
chasing the light.
It was to be the second
ever Arctic expedition with
the mission of creating art
inspired by the dramatic geography there.
And the first was led in 1869 by an
American painter named William Bradford.
And what was unique about that trip was
that its main purpose was art as opposed
to science or exploration,
which is what was happening in that day.
So my mom thought,
well,
wouldn't it be fascinating to Mirror
Bradford's for journey and travel up the
northwest coast of Greenland to seek
inspiration from the same landscape nearly
150 years after Bradford had.
So she and I were in the very early
stages of planning this trip when she was
diagnosed with brain cancer.
And the cancer pretty quickly
took over her body and her mind,
and she passed away six months later.
But during those six months,
during those months of her illness,
her dedication to the
expedition never wavered.
And so it felt like a duty to me.
Like I felt responsible to carry
out this mission in her honor,
which I did in August of 2012 leading a
group of artists and scholars on a four
week expedition.
My mother's affection for the landscape
really echoed throughout my own
experience in Greenland.
And I felt both the power but also
the fragility of the landscape.
I mean,
the sheer size of the icebergs
is humbling and the ice fields,
they like vibrate with movement and
sound in a way that I never expected.
That's what prompted me to
bring my recording equipment
and my more recent trips
so I could bring that back to you.
And it's also why I decided to expand
the scale of my work to give viewers that
same sense of awe that I had experienced.
The melting glaciers in Greenland are one
of the largest contributing factors to
rising sea levels,
which have already begun to drown some
of our world's lowest lying islands.
One year after my trip to Greenland,
I decided to fly to the Maldives,
which is the lowest and flatus
country and the entire world.
And while I was there,
I collected images and inspiration
for a new body of work,
drawings of waves lapping
along the coast of a nation,
a whole nation that could be entirely
underwater within this century.
While I was there with my collaborators,
we shared the concept of our project
with children at the Iskander elementary
school,
the nation's Capitol called Molly.
And we basically just invited them to
document their landscape as it transforms
throughout their lifetime.
Um,
and hopefully that can help to
bring awareness to their island,
which is actually still very much needed,
surprisingly enough.
And I'm also just help
them kind of inwardly,
emotionally process what
is happening around them.
Last winter,
I had the honor of serving as the
artist and residents aboard the National
Geographic explorer in Antarctica.
I've traveled to many stunning places,
but Antarctica is just
in a category of its own.
The ice,
just like radiated a sapphire blue,
as you can see in this video.
And it just took my breath away.
It's what inspired a whole body
of work that I just completed,
that I worked on for the last 18 months.
Um,
and I'll just show you a time
lapse of one of those pieces. Um,
it's called Wale Bay. It was inspired
by a place called Oil Bay, uh,
that's on the Antarctic peninsula.
And the bay is situated near a glacier
that's calving icebergs into the sea as
all glaciers eventually do.
But the wind and water currents carry the
icebergs directly into the bay because
of where it's situated.
And since the bay is kind of shallow,
the icebergs will scrape against the sea
floor and become what's called grounded,
which basically means they remained
there until they've melted completely,
which is a process that can take years
if the icebergs are large enough, like,
like this one. Um, and
bays that enclose icebergs,
like these are called iceberg graveyards,
which to me just seems like a
metaphor for the bigger picture. Um,
you know,
I had the opportunity to ride around
this bay for two hours in a small Zodiac
boat.
This is a video that I took there.
A Zodiac has a little rubberized
like 12 foot boat. Um, and you,
you'll actually start to see the iceberg
on the righthand side come into view.
That's the iceberg from the drawing
that you just saw me making. Um,
it's from a slightly different angles,
so if you don't recognize it,
it's not my fault. Um, but yeah,
we got to ride around for two hours
just weaving around the most intricately
sculpted, glowing blue icebergs
I have ever seen. I mean, the,
the longer that they stay there,
the more the water and the wind sculpt
these blocks of ice into just other
worldly shapes.
And I shot like thousands of photographs,
um,
at times I had to just force my camera
into my lap so I could simply be present
and take in the overwhelming
beauty of it all.
And so I hope that my drawings as much
as you can see on these screens can offer
you a similar experience.
Um,
so this past October I had the opportunity
see Antarctica from a whole different
perspective. NASA invited me to
join them on operation ice bridge,
which is the largest airborne
survey of earth's polar ice.
Um,
we flew 12 hours every single day
that the weather permitted on the DC,
which has the most comprehensive suite
of instruments ever flown on long range
flights, including laser
radar, an infrared sensor,
digital photography,
and something called a groove
emitter that houses Einstein's brain.
But it like measures gravity
somehow. I don't know. Um,
and it was just,
I mean it was an incredible experience.
It was humbling to witness the science
team and air crews dedication to their
seriously hard and grueling work and
the data collected provides crucial
information about ice loss.
Basically what the melting of ice sheets
could mean for sea level rise and what
the melting of sea ice could mean
for the entire global climate system.
This year, the Antarctic Sea ice
loss has been particularly swift.
We even had to make some
last minute modifications to
one of our flight plans to
account for the significantly diminished
cis when NASA measured its extent for
this time of year,
it was at the lowest level ever
recorded and reliable satellite history,
which dates all the way back
to 1979 and since that year,
since 1979,
the planet has been shedding massive
amounts of cis annually that equal the
amount of, um, an area larger
than the state of Maryland.
The scale of this loss is
difficult to comprehend.
Um,
and similarly,
my sense of perspective was completely
warped as we flew over the ice.
And just to give you an example of that,
this is a photo from one of our flights
over glacier called land glacier and it
covers the equivalent of 54 football
fields in that photo is just,
I mean, it's crazy to me. It looks like a
little crumble advice like the sidewalk,
but that little blue crack is
probably a hundred feet wide.
Um,
so this past April,
I was actually able to join NASA is ice
bridge team again on some of their art
dick missions. And we
flew over, um, ice sheets,
CIS and glaciers,
Arctic Canada and Greenland.
And it was just, I mean, totally
thrilling to fly once again,
only 1500 feet above the ice that's there.
The instruments need to be 1500 feet.
So it's,
it's actually pretty low for a plane and
you really get to see the detail and it
was just like so exciting for
me to compare the ice to it,
southern counterpart,
um,
but also just reconnects with the
science team and the air crew and um,
kind of chilling to learn of some of
their more recent discoveries such as a
giant crack that is forming
in the Peterman glacier,
which could in the future. This is a
picture of the crack. Um, so it could,
if it splits off the shelf,
you mean a new Ice Island?
Basically a giant iceberg that's
twice the size of Manhattan
findings from this close to a decade now.
Long project are numerous and
some of them mind blowing to me.
For instance,
they found a canyon larger than the
Grand Canyon under Greenland's ice sheet,
just like we had no idea that was there.
It was just hiding under the ice sheet
bigger than the Grand Canyon. Um,
but the most significant data from the
project have shown that the entire West
Antarctic ice sheet has likely entered
an unstable state and might now be in
irreversible decline.
And although the timing of
that retreat is unknown,
it's still a powerful reminder that
we've entered a new era with significant
changes on the horizon.
Our president has already begun to
defund NASA climate research and the lead
scientist at iceberg named Nathan cards
recently emailed the team and I to say,
quote,
in these uncertain times,
it is vitally important that we reach
the hearts and minds of people around the
world to communicate the importance
of the work that we're doing. Right.
So I just want to thank you for having
this opportunity to share not only their
really important mission, but also my
own work. Um, and I hope that, you know,
you'll spread it as much as you
can and it's just an honor to,
to speak to such an influential audience.
So when I was in Greenland in two
back in 2012, that first trip,
I scattered my mother's ashes amidst the
melting ice and now she remains a part
of the landscape that she loved so much,
even as it two passes
and takes on new forms.
Among the many gifts that my mom gave
me was the ability to focus on the
positive rather than
dwell in the negative.
And honestly,
that lesson has rarely felt more
necessary than now. And yes,
it's become far more challenging to
stay positive since January especially.
But I'm doing my best and I
encourage others to do the same.
And former Secretary General Ban,
Ki Moon said at the most recent
climate change conference in Morocco,
that action on climate change
has become unstoppable.
And he's absolutely right.
And those are the words that
I just keep reminding myself,
mmm.
On our family travels.
Every time that we came across
a really spectacular view,
my mom would do this thing and I apologize
in advance because I'm going to have
to get loud. She would go, oh my God.
And that in taste cause I sound
exactly like hers. Um, but it was,
she's, it was special. Like she saved
it for only the best of the best.
And so it would happen once,
usually maybe twice if we were lucky on
a four to six week trip on each four to
six week trip. And so every single time
we approached a really beautiful view,
my dad and my sister and I would like
glance at her wondering if it passed the
test.
I tried to uphold her reverence,
her legacy of drawing attention to
the beauty of these remote places.
And I tried to embody her,
resolve an intrepid newness.
I am so utterly grateful for the time
that I had with her and also for the time
that we all have to appreciate what is
around us and to take action to protect
it.
Thank you.
So, but what are we going to do?
A Q and. A, but I also have, um,
a video piece that is also premiering
currently and my solo show in Seattle.
And it's kind of subtle.
I recorded it on the Antarctic peninsula,
same place where I did that drawing
that I showed you the timelapse up. Um,
and so I'm just gonna let it play in
the background while you guys ask me
questions.
And here it is.
Maybe here we go.
Is there ever a question
about a technology and how
it's been used to amplify
your message? I'm Seth
talked about reddit. Oh,
I know what the campaign that you raised
money too for the trip to Greenland. Um,
and then now with Youtube,
uh,
can you talk a little bit more
about how technology is helping, uh,
with the momentum as you say?
Yeah. Um, yeah, a few years ago my,
as Seth mentioned,
my work kind of went viral on the
Internet then I have still to this don't
really know how it happened,
but I'm grateful for it. Um,
and the momentum that that started
hasn't really ever stopped.
And,
um,
I mean I think like I had done enough
work in the 10 years previous to kind of
like back to back that up. Like it was
like a ripe time for it to happen. Um,
but I'm certainly really grateful that
it did cause it just helped. I mean,
it's so easy to spread these
kinds of messages really far, um,
across the planet, across the globe. And,
um, yeah. And so I really use, you know,
like especially Instagram, social
media as a tool to, to share, you know,
these the missions I went on with NASA
and also just the work that I'm doing.
Um, what was it? Did I, did I answer
everything you ask? Yeah. Okay, cool.
Yeah. Oh, also, I shouldn't say that
like Instagram itself has really become,
I think,
like the best way for artists especially
to promote their work because it's such,
it's such a visual platform. So, um, yeah,
I mean I've sold a lot of work
on Instagram, which is, you know,
that never would have
happened 10 years ago.
It's just interesting
how things have changed.
Hi. Hi. First of all,
thank you for your very beautiful
work and your positive energy, uh,
on a topic that I think is
pretty tough and scary. Um,
my main question is, with your
work, what is your main goal?
Is it to document and share or to
inspire or are you urging people to take
action? Like just people like
us or organization or politics?
Yeah, good question. Um,
my main purpose is to share,
to give viewers a place,
a time and a moment to feel like they're,
they're like they're transported to these
places that are otherwise like so not
connected to our everyday lives.
Um,
and to ideally stir up an emotional
connection because like I said,
you know, when you, when you have an
emotional connection with something,
when you love something,
you want to protect it.
And so that's the idea is that I spur
that emotional connection and then they go
on to take action. And I do, you
know, I'll, I'll offer things,
I'll give websites, I'd donate a
percent of my sales to three fifty.org,
but I have a whole page
on my website that's like,
here's how you can cut down
your carbon footprint. Um,
but I feel like there's a lot of
that out there, which is awesome.
And that's not like my main
purpose. Even though, yeah,
of course I want to direct people in the
right way so that they can take action,
but I'm trying to translate the,
the debt,
like the data is out, like we know
the science, but somehow still,
almost half of our planet doesn't believe
it or just doesn't want to see it.
And so clearly that hard science isn't
enough. So I'm trying to just offer,
you know, the best way
that I can communicate the
importance of that and the,
and the scientific stuff that might
not be as easy to digest and have an
emotional connection
with. Thank you. Yeah,
that's very great. I know, me too.
Yeah, thank you as well.
It's really inspiring,
not only to see some of the
context behind what you're doing,
but also how you do it.
So I liked that you touched on both
pieces and actually how you work with the,
um,
pastels and,
and what the reasoning behind it and
to touch on your last point of, um,
kind of accessibility of the message.
Right? So I think the data is out there,
the science is out there
that's very difficult for a
lot of us to understand and
many more to understand.
Right?
And so I think sometimes these decisions
are emotionally driven rather than
driven by the data and the science
backing it up. And I'm just curious,
I think the way that you're going about
it kind of tried to create an emotional
reaction is probably making this a
more accessible message then maybe NASA
message or something to
a much bigger audience.
And I was wondering if you
could just touch upon that,
if you've seen that you're able to, um,
make that message more accessible, um,
or maybe any lessons learned do you
have from making that a more accessible
message?
Yeah, absolutely. I mean,
and that's exactly what I'm
trying to do. So thank you.
I'm glad that you think gets it.
It's doing that. Um, and I, uh,
a big part of that too is the,
the, the realistic way that I draw,
like the way that I'm, I'm drawing all
the details. It's not abstract. It's, um,
accessible not only to people who
aren't interested in science but also,
um, people outside the
art world bubble. Um,
I get a lot of like people who want to,
who have purchased my work and you
want to our first time art buyers,
like they just want to be able to
see that image in their home. Um,
cause you know,
I think there,
there is a lot of art out there that's
not so accessible and this is just like
you look at an image and,
and you know,
you know what it's about and you can
have a connection to it because it's part
of our planet. We all live here. So yeah,
I mean in every facet I try to
make it as accessible as possible.
And I do think that it's, um,
succeeding in that way. You know,
hopefully I get, you know, of course
the only people only tell me, you know,
that they love my work. I don't tell me
if they hate it. So, but, um, but yeah,
I mean I have had a bunch of people come
up to me and just say like, thank you.
Like I had no idea.
Or like now I've changed these actions
in my life because of what you said.
And so that's like the most
gratifying things that I can hear.
Yeah.
Hi.
You said that you take thousands of
images and you have access to videos.
So how do you choose which
images to actually draw?
Oh, good question. Um, that's, it's
probably the hardest part of my job,
I think.
Um,
it takes hours and hours of just scrolling
through and editing because I, I mean,
at this point I have like
lifetimes over enough material to,
to continue making work for,
for many lives. And, um, and,
and I still want to go back and,
and continue be inspired by
these places selfishly. But, uh,
it's,
it's hard to describe because I think a
lot of the time it's just like a feeling
like I'll be scrolling through images
and then all of a sudden something will
really stand out to me.
Um,
and so that's often how it happens is
just like the composition just feels
right. It's not about math
or like, um, you know,
art theory about the horizon line has
to be one third up from the bottom.
It's just, I was just like, oh,
there's something about that that just
like has the right feeling. Um, yeah.
And it,
and it can be hard because even I have
an endless amount of photos and video,
but then I can also crop them
endlessly and zoom in endlessly.
So, yeah, it's definitely
the hardest part.
I spent a lot of time scrolling through
and staring at their computer screen and
lots of icy pictures.
I'm wondering what comes next after the
icebergs and the disappearing islands in
the Maldives where you sort of stay on
theme with environmental changes or maybe
do something else entirely?
Um, yeah, I mean, I, you
know, I can't tell the future,
but I do think that I could continue with
ice and sea level rise for the rest of
my life. Um, I don't feel like, and like,
and until it stops inspiring me,
I'm going to continue with it.
And I don't see that end anywhere
in sight. And just because there,
there's so much more that I still
have to learn about rendering.
It's different textures and surfaces and,
and that's what excites me and just to
like learn something new with every piece.
And so immediately what's next is,
um,
from all these trips I did with NASA,
I gathered a bunch of aerial
footage and photography and, um,
and I'll be making a series
that's from that perspective.
So some of those photos you saw
it all kind of look like that.
It's a little bit more abstract
looking and won't, it's, it's real.
It won't look abstract. But, um,
I'm curious to see, you know,
how that all unfolded
and it's exciting for me,
but that'll be my next exhibit in
New York, um, in October of 2018.
So, but yeah, like I said,
there's just so many textures and
surfaces and ways that it's like melting.
I mean water has so many
different forms and, um,
I just don't see an end in sight where it,
where it will stop inspiring me.
And I also think,
you know,
climate change is like arguably the
largest crisis we face as a global
community. And I don't see
that going away anytime soon.
And so it's important to me to connect
whatever I'm doing to something, um,
you know,
meaningful for the rest of the world.
So I see myself doing that
forever. Thank you. Yeah.
Thank you.
Anyone else?
So when you're drawing,
are we making a conscious effort
to stop yourself from exploring and
transforming the image,
the photograph or like how the hell do
you trade off between kind of maintaining
the accuracy of the photograph
and going into an abstract thing?
Yeah. Um, I mean, I'm, I,
I want to portray the exact landscape
that I witnessed because I'm trying to
stay true to it. And, you know,
I just want to be honest about what I
saw and tried to give people that same
experience. So the only
time I ever, um, you know,
elaborate or change it,
it's a very small percent of the time,
but it's really just like if I have this
beautiful image and I feel like is like
really more powerful than
anything else, you know, um,
that I've been looking through.
But there was like, oh,
the corner of the iceberg goes off
the corner of the image and I don't,
I want it to stay contained inside with
a little bit of background behind it.
It's just that just to like artistically
creative bonds composition so that it
gives you, you know, as much of
a, uh, a wonderful, comfortable,
loving feeling as possible.
Yeah.
Hi. Sorry, ma'am. Could you
talk a bit more about, um,
the collaboration with NASA in that,
how did that come about for
you as an artist? Yeah, so, um,
one day I got an email from,
um,
from NASA is,
uh,
he was a navigator is basically their
lead navigator for airborne terrestrial
exploration, not extraterrestrial.
So like basically flying,
exploring arth from, from flight, you
know, in flight. And he just reached out.
He came from a family of artists and
I mean he didn't say that in his first
email, but he was just like,
Hey, I found your work on,
I saw your Ted talk on apple TV in my,
you know,
preparations and research for
my next trip to Antarctica.
And I thought you shouldn't come with us.
And so here's my phone number, call me.
I had,
if I remember very clearly this day,
I had a friend we know coworking with
me in my studio and I was like, wow,
I read him the email. He was
like, oh my God. I was like,
I think I'm going to call him immediately,
but I kinda think this is a hoax.
And I called him and he had this
like radio voice and I was like,
this just can't be a real.
Um,
and after several conversations in
several months and lots of planning,
I still didn't think it was real on the
plane flying down to Punta Arenas, Chile,
where I was going to meet the team.
And it really wasn't until like the,
that evening when I walked into the first
science meeting that they have every
night at 6:00 PM where
I was like, oh, this is,
I'm not being kidnapped there.
An appointment of NASA scientists here.
So yeah, I, I mean I'm just,
I'm so grateful for this opportunity and
to collaborate with such an incredible
project and, um, and I was so
intimidated to at first to,
to go meet a bunch of, you know,
I'm an artist, I'm a weird,
quirky artists to go meet a bunch of
NASA scientists was like really scary,
but they were so warm and welcoming and
a bunch of them had even like known my
work before and we're really excited
to meet me and, and you know,
way more than I expected. They
really valued the, you know,
understood the value in communicating
their message in a different way that they
haven't been able to do.
So I think all of them are like really
grateful that I was there and doing,
doing what I'm doing. So it's, it's
been a really incredible experience.
I'm actually going there tonight.
Right after I leave here,
I'm getting a hundred chain and I'm
going to be speaking at Nasa Goddard
tomorrow. So I'm excited
to see all of them. Yeah.
All right. Thank you. Hi. Um,
there's definitely like an element of
scale in your work and I think, uh,
also in how you're,
you're really amplifying the
message and um, you know,
this change, I think like you, you had
an image up there that was, you know,
some cracks and you're like,
that crack right there,
it could be a hundred feet across.
Like I'm curious about
how you think about scale,
like did your work start at
a smaller scale and um, yeah,
just more on that.
Yeah, I, I um, I consider it,
I guess like my professional work began
in my last year in college and I was
working pretty big actually. I made a
couple of, um, eight foot, you know,
step six by eight foot pieces
for my senior show. And, um,
and I was drawing a really big, you
know, sky's storms, hurricanes, um,
from like whether photography and,
um,
so scale has always been important to me,
but especially after I got back from
that first trip to Antarctica and the
winter of 2015,
I was just like,
how can I do this landscape justice,
um,
without going as hugely massive
as possible, as you know, as,
as much as I can afford and
can do in my studio. Um,
because it's just so epic and it's
like you can use all these, you know,
grandiose words and it's like
nothing really describes it.
And that's why I'm trying to draw them
because I don't know how to put it into
words, but, um, so yeah,
I feel like the scale is really important
to make you feel like you're, you're,
you know, standing in front of a
glacier, you really, you need that scale.
It's so important. And so,
um, I do work, you know,
I make smaller pieces is
kind of more like studies,
but also just because there are so
much easier to transport and, and so,
um, but the, the, the larger ones
are really where my heart is.
I love to spend a whole
year working on one piece,
making it as large as I possibly can.
So if,
you know anyone that
wants to pay for that,
but yeah, it's one thing that
people tend to comment on.
So I'll just say something about it is
like there isn't a lot of the drawings or
most of them,
there isn't really a sense
of scale because I'm not
putting a little penguin in
there, a little boat. Um, and,
and I, I kinda, you know, I,
part of me wishes that there were
something I could put in there that didn't
seem cheesy like a penguin, um, that
would offer that sense of scale.
But, uh, on the flip side, I think it's
kind of Nice sometimes because there,
there are drawings that I showed
you in this presentation where, um,
like an iceberg was maybe as
big as the drawing itself. Um,
but people think it's like when people
ask me, they're like, how big is that?
Because it looks like a mountain range
to me. I'm like, oh, that's great.
It was this pig.
And I actually like when they think
it's like larger than than life. Um,
but I love especially drawing at like
a one one ratio as much as possible,
meaning the scope, the scale of the ice
was actually as big as I'm drawing it. Uh,
cause it just allows me to really get
into all the nitty gritty details and just
like show you show viewer is exactly what
the ice texture it looks like up close.
Thank you.
Yeah.
First I think Google should
pay for that gigantic
drawing somehow. I'll,
I'll, we'll email after.
Yeah. So, uh, I, I really
liked how you shared the sound
with us and it sound is it,
it seems like it's definitely, um, uh,
an attribute that will help
people get more embarrassed. Um,
and so I'm curious if you collaborating
also with people that can create VR
experiences or interactive experiences
and sort of like scale it in a different
way. I like you, you know,
uh, the topic and everything,
but you can probably share it yeah.
In different mediums as well.
Yeah,
it is definitely a direction that
I see myself going in especially,
I mean, this exhibit
that's up right now, um,
is the first one where I've
shown that sounded piece,
I played you as my first sound piece.
The video piece I was playing during
the Q and a is my first video and um,
the exhibit in Seattle right now,
I was really trying to create that
kind of immersive experience like you
mentioned because it just
allows you to feel like you're,
they're that much more and Vr
is like almost at this point,
like the ultimate of that.
And so, yes, I would,
I would really love to venture into
that arena. And, you know, I've,
I've been,
you know,
just starting conversations with people
and thinking about projects in the works,
but nothing is, is planned yet. But yeah,
definitely in direction I want to go in.
Okay.
I feel like everyone
here asked a question.
Thank you. Oh yeah. Really fast.
And I feel a little bad at asking after a,
you've explained why the
scale is so important,
but can we purchase prince
anywhere and well, yeah, no,
that's a great sense.
Okay. Yeah. Right now.
So I'm art star.com sells.
My friends used to be [inaudible].
Now we also have, um, a new print that
just came out of that, that first slide,
if you,
I dunno if I want to pull it up there,
but I'm the one that I first showed you
of me. Like I'm in the corner drawing it.
It's one big, the of the
time lapse drying. Um,
that one is a new print now that's offered
through Winston walked her in Seattle.
So you just have to call the
gallery. But um, yeah. And we're,
we're launching a new print soon,
and yeah,
and then there'll be new
drawings available as I start
making this next series.
Thank you.